PolyPhen-2 is an automatic tool
for prediction of the possible
impact of an amino acid substitution on the
structure and function of a human protein.
Automated predictions of this kind are
essential for interpreting large datasets
of rare genetic variants, which have many
applications in modern human genetics research.
Uses in recent research include identifying
rare alleles that cause Mendelian disease,
scanning for potentially medically
actionable alleles in an individual’s genome,
and profiling the spectrum of rare variation
uncovered by deep sequencing of large populations.
PolyPhen predicts functional effects of amino acid
variations based on both multi-sequence alignment
and protein 3D structure features. It is based on
three presumptions. The first is the same as in
SIFT, that amino acid variations at conserved
positions are more likely to cause functional
changes. The second presumption is that amino
acid variations that affect the active sites,
interaction sites, solubility, or stability of a
protein are likely to affect protein structure.
The third presumption is that changes
in protein structure are likely to cause
changes in protein function, which are
likely to cause changes in phenotype.
PolyPhen-2 uses eight sequence-based and three
structure-based predictive features which were
selected automatically by an iterative greedy
algorithm. Majority of these features involve
comparison of a property of the wild-type
allele and the corresponding property of
the mutant allele, which together
define an amino acid replacement.
Most informative features characterize how well
the two human alleles fit into the pattern of
amino acid replacements within the multiple
sequence alignment of homologous proteins,
how distant the protein harboring the first
deviation from the human wild-type allele is
from the human protein, and whether the mutant
allele originated at a hypermutable site. The
alignment pipeline selects the set of homologous
sequences for the analysis using a clustering
algorithm and then constructs and refines their
multiple alignment. The functional significance
of an allele replacement is predicted from its
individual features by Naïve Bayes classifier
In this example, we will investigate the
effects of p53 R273H mutation. In the “Protein
or SNP identifier” text box, enter a protein
identifier. PolyPhen-2 uses the UniProtKB database
as a reference source for all protein sequences
and annotations. You can also enter human protein
identifiers from other databases such
as RefSeq or standard gene symbols.
However, UniProtKB identifiers are preferred
as the most reliable and unambiguous.
Leave the “Protein sequence in FASTA format”
text box empty. Enter the position of the
substitution in the protein sequence into the
Position text box. For this example, type 273.
Select the appropriate boxes for
the wild-type amino acid residue AA1
and the substitution residue AA2. For this
example, select “R” for AA1 and “H” for AA2,
respectively. Enter an optional description
into the “Query description” text box.
Click the Submit Query button. You will be
transferred to the Grid Gateway Interface Web
page. Use the Refresh button to reload the page
until your query job is listed under Completed.
Click the corresponding View link to browse the
PolyPhen-2 prediction report for your query.
You will be presented with the Web page
listing your Query and the Prediction
and Confidence panel. Prediction outcome can
be one of probably damaging, possibly damaging,
or benign. “Score” is the probability of the
substitution being damaging. “Sensitivity” and
“specificity” correspond to prediction confidence.
The predicted damaging effect is also indicated by
a vertical black marker inside a color gradient
bar, where green is benign and red is damaging.
By default, only the prediction
based on the HumDiv model is shown.
Click on the [+] control box next to the HumVar
label to display the HumVar-based prediction
and scores. Click on the [+] control box next
to “Multiple sequence alignment” to display
the multiple sequence alignment panel. This
panel displays a multiple sequence alignment
for 75 amino acid residues surrounding your
variant’s position in the query sequence.
Click the link at the bottom of the panel
to open an interactive alignment viewer
to scroll through the complete alignment.
Click on the [+] control box next to 3-D
Visualization to display the interactive
3-D protein structure viewer applet.